welcome to the reason stream I'm Zach
Weiss Muller and today I'm speaking with
Lynn Alden an investment analyst and
founder of Lyn Alden investment strategy
and author of broken money why our
financial system is failing Us and how
we can make it better this book is an
incredible torta force that lays out the
history of money from its Inception to
present
takes you deep into the dueling schools
of thought around money's Origins and
fundamental properties offers a
macroanalysis of today's monetary and
fiscal situation worldwide and lays out
a path forward for transitioning the
world to better more sound money in the
future if you care about any of this and
really who doesn't care about money this
one is a mustre Lin Alden I'm very
excited to have the opportunity to talk
about this with you thank you for
joining me today thank you for having me
always happy to be here the opening
section of your book is titled what is
money and spoiler alert your answer is
that it's at its core money is a ledger
how did you come to that conclusion and
what do you mean by it so i' I've that's
not something that appears a lot in
literature I've heard it said by a
number of people um and I later found
out that ventes Garis had a number of um
talks that he gave on that subject so
it's it's not a it's not something that
I completely made up but it's something
that uh just does not really get a lot
of exploration in literature anywhere um
as far as I can tell and the way that I
interpret that the way that I came to
that is basically to to kind of realize
that when we trade around physical
commodity monies like coins if you
picture this from like a high level like
if you if you could remove the fog of
war and just kind of like had an
omniscience site into what's going on we
are basically updating a ledger of coins
by physical possession and physical
transfer uh even though we don't think
of it as a ledger it's a ledger that
exists that none of us know the complete
Ledger uh and yet nonetheless it's still
there and so really what it comes down
to is when we when we are using money in
some form we're either relying on the
properties of nature to basically
control the parameters of The Ledger uh
for our savings our payments uh things
like that
um or we're relying on human controlled
ledgers like more what we think of as a
literal Ledger uh could be clay tablets
in Babylon could be a modern Central
Bank could be a a normal Banks you know
just their
Ledger and so these are the different
basically ways that we kind of disc
coordinate what units exist how are new
units of that Ledger made uh how are
they updated between each party um and
who who ultimately controls the The
Ledger either in terms of being able to
stop transactions uh if anyone or who
can who can create more units and if so
how uh and so I think that that kind of
reconciles both the commodity money uh
Theory and the credit money Theory um by
kind of just taking that broader View
and that question of who controls the
Ledger is really Central to your book
why is that such an important question
to
consider because that changes over time
uh based on the Technologies and the
ledgers that we use basically we we
generally gravitated from commodity
Monies to bank and Central Bank ledgers
and so the answer basically used to be
that before no one really controlled it
uh it was it was fairly
decentralized then we get like small
levels of control through for example
coinage and and slow to basement and
seniorage uh basically a little bit of
kind of control over the money but now
in the modern form when literally the
money that we use is merely a central
bank balance sheet like a do is not
redeemable for anything it doesn't owe
you any specific goods or services all
it is is basically the Central Bank it
the monetary base is the liability side
of the central bank so just basically by
maintaining their Ledger and trying to
have that not grow too quickly is what
is what we are using as money um and so
the reason who controls it is important
is because it's not always obvious who
controls it and if you're using a money
for which it's controlled and you don't
know who controls it or what parameters
it's it's operating under um basically
value gets siphoned away from you and so
when when I kind of compare and contrast
different types of monies in the book I
I go through that step by step to each
one because who controls it is one of
the points of difference between
different types of money and a really
interesting aspect of the book is you
walk us through how we move from one to
another you know this is an example of
kind of one of the earliest earlier
forms of money these polished shells
uh commodity money where like as you
said The Ledger was controlled by nature
in some sense and then you say in the
book that gold is the king of
Commodities what is it that makes gold
so special in the history of money
basically it's got the highest stock to
flow ratio meaning that the amount of
gold that's out there in human
possession um that that's the the total
stock of gold that exists uh in that
refined for the flow of new gold uh is
very low compared to the existing stock
so it's like 1.5% per year roughly uh
and it's a pretty stable number um in
any given kind of multi-decade period
and what that means is that we don't
dilute the amount of gold very quickly
in fact it's been roughly in line with
population growth uh historically which
doesn't really have to be the case but
just roughly has been and so really if
you hold a gold coin your rate of
getting diluted in terms of your share
of all gold that exist exist is very
very slow compared to many other um
monies compared to many other
Commodities and basically as humans gain
more technology so as we went through
the Industrial Revolution or even before
then just as we got more metal tooling
uh went through those different eras of
monetary technology we got way better at
making certain types of money and we
basically broke their stock to flow
ratio so if we find out that some
culture uses shells as money and we have
metal tools and like more advanced boats
and things like that we can go and
indust ize the process and just flood
them with money and and get whatever
they were willing to sell that's scarcer
for it same thing is true for you know
there are people to try to use tobacco
as money or coco as money uh a little
bit harder you get to like copper as
money uh but we find ways to like make a
lot more of those things and can change
the existing Supply uh very quickly but
what makes gold uh unique and to some
extent gold and silver but especially
gold is that we even with our modern
technology we still can't uh make it
quickly um even during the 1970s when
the gold price in dollars went up by an
order of magnitude if you just look at
the um percent annual Supply growth of
gold so not just the absolute tonnage
but the the new tonnage compared to the
estimated existing tonnage you won't
really notice the 70s on the chart
looking any different than the 60s or
the 80s or any other decade with the
within the century um basically it's
it's one of those Commodities where the
price um only slowly and and not hugely
affects how much we get out of the
ground and that's because it's it's so
energy intensive um per ounce uh it's
it's hard to find and develop deposits
and there's a na natural difficulty
adjustment so as we've um over time as
our technolog is better we get better at
mining gold but also the easy deposits
are already mined I mean basically
humans have spent thousands of years
finding gold and so the deepest and and
most challenging deposits remain and so
even as our technology does get better
at least so far we've that's not really
translated into us being able to break
that money in a similar way that we can
we can break almost any other money uh
with the acception of these kind of more
like very rare ones so the that
intrinsic property of gold made it the
reigning money for a long time the the
story of how we and why the world moved
away from a gold standard or gold as
money is is fascinating and important
you are kind of a technological
determinist in this respect not that
there's anything wrong with that I come
from a similar perspective actually but
why was the demise of gold as money a
technological inevitability in your view
I think so whenever we see something
happen everywhere uh and nearly all at
once uh we have to start thinking that
it probably wasn't a specifical
political a specific political decision
or some sort of thing that that you know
has a high chance of turning out
differently it's something that if it
happens everywhere uh we have to really
ask why what what incentive structure
changed or what made the prior thing
untenable and what I argue in the book
is that ever since the dawn of the
Telecommunications age so the the
invention of the telegraph in the 1830s
but more specifically the the widespread
deployment of it which really kind of
kicked off in the 1860s um that made it
so that we were now in an increasingly
telecommunication connected world
transactions could be done overseas uh
you know within seconds and minutes uh
and the physical transfer of gold was a
slow process especially when you
consider auditing it uh verifying that
you actually got the gold which can
actually be surprisingly challenging um
and so we had to increasingly abstract
gold in order to keep up uh and by
abstracting it uh we built these very
layered um sets of claims on it and so
one one source that I cite in the book
is William Stanley jevans uh 18 1975
money in the mechanism of exchange and
what's interesting about that book is
that you know he's he's looking at real
time at the money system it's still
pretty early in the international gold
standard so plenty of countries had be
using gold but this was like after the
franor Prussian War there was peace
across Europe they were basically on
this like shared International gold
standard that was operating very
smoothly and he was pointing out that
it's almost it's almost too efficient
for its own good that basically gold
rarely moves all these paper claims and
and Telegraph Claims can move around and
it's all basically just one giant
Central database in London at this point
uh like this big Central Clearing House
and he's on one hand he's like basically
this is great it's it's hyper efficient
other hand he's saying that um it's
lever 20 to one because no one ever
takes their gold out and we just assume
maximum efficiency and we assume people
aren't going to take their gold out
because who would take their gold out
because then you're you're pulling your
gold out of this telecommunication
connected uh super Global Ledger um but
he's like if we have to can't can't
forget that these claims uh are all
redeemable for gold and so and of course
what happened in World War I was all of
that completely broke um and so I think
the the fundamental problem with gold is
that it can't move quickly enough in the
telecommunication age and so it was the
first time where speed became a variable
in money um prior to then we mostly just
went up the hardness tree for different
monies like how hard is it to make more
of that money uh as our technology got
better and better and we eventually
landed on gold um but now uh in that
world you know without centralization
abstraction gold just doesn't keep up
and the problem is that when you
centralize things that much and
eventually the system blows up people
just stick with the claims they don't
they don't let the claims collapse 95%
back down to the monetary base they
instead just break the peg or just
disregard gold allog together and start
using these inherently abstract ledgers
uh that are just maintained by some
degree of stability with the central
bank and some some divisions of powers
that determine how is money created what
are the checks and balances obviously
some some currencies last longer than
others and so we've kind of found
ourselves in a situation where we use a
money that is for the first time a step
back in hardness um but it's faster and
this has come with all sorts of um
challenges in the modern era but I think
if would have rerun this multiple times
the fact that we have a big gap between
transaction speeds and settlement speeds
is something that would recreate this
problem probably over and over again so
one of the problems that you very
quickly get to with that tradeoff of you
know trading the hardness for the speed
and this is something that you you hear
from many Libertarians especially fans
of Ron Paul and ending the FED is that
once it's all about the money printer
and it it the creation of money gets so
centralized that that fuels War uh you
lay that out in detail using World War I
and Britain as an example how many
things have gone differently I know
counterfactuals are hard but can you
imagine what a different situation it
might have been if Fiat money had not
come into
existence around World War
I so I think that it's not that fiat
currency came in existing around world I
I think it's actually kind of the
opposite World War I it part was a World
War because that was kind of the first
major war where it this this world now
existed this telecommunication enhanced
gold standard system could be readily
rug pulled so prior prior to that point
whenever a country wanted to debase its
current so it wants to go to war taxes
are unpopular it's hard to tell someone
we have to raise your taxes to go kill
these people on this other continent you
know it's it's it's if you're being
invaded it's one thing but if you're
going to go invade others or do things
like that it's hard to sell that uh and
so rulers have historically turned to
the basement uh but the basement is
actually a pretty slow process with
coinage um you have to physically pull
the money in with taxes or other methods
remelt it into these you know debased
forms making use of the fact that you
can get more coins with that uh and so
it takes time to to pull that in remelt
it and then uh try to do it in such a
way that not super obvious and it just
kind of you just kind of boil the Frog
slowly so to speak um what made this
world different is that with everybody
putting their money in Banks um and
Banks then became big honeypots right so
instead of going to get everyone's gold
a country could be like well there's
like you know kind of 10 banks in the
country and we can just we can just with
a stroke of a pen we can be like okay so
all of that has to be deposited at the
central bank and you're all going to use
the same Ledger now it's just very easy
to Central once something becomes
centralized it's easy for it to be
centrally controlled as well um and so
in that era where everybody's Gold's in
the banking system the banking system is
centralized and basically the government
Central Bank have most of the gold in
their
control um or even just on member banks
but they know where it is and they can
easily just uh create rules about who
can you know redeem it or if they have
to turn it over physically things like
that once that's all in place
literally a stroke of a pen can just say
well all those Bank claims you have are
now cut in half relative to Gold
overnight uh it's a much faster
debasement process uh you can even
debase foreign holders of your currency
and bonds very easily um so basically
it's the the the the speed and the power
with which you can rug pull people uh to
allocate that value towards war is
significantly enhanced and so I think if
you were to rerun the opening of World
War I before this in this techn just
wasn't around yet it's unclear that it
would have spread nearly as wide as it
did because you know the the the number
of entities that got in at the size they
did was in largest part due to that
printing printing press um and that's
something that it's you know it's hard
to say what the world would have looked
like uh had that not happened but I do
think that it's not a coincidence that
they were that they were somewhat
conjoined in that way yeah it's that's
interesting it's uh almost a mclite
reading of History you know where the
the medium is the message in this case
the the change in media was
telecommunications which allowed money
which then reshaped history and I think
there's there's a lot that's compelling
about that analysis when we look at the
medium of exchange the money you know we
went from shells to Gold to paper money
representing gold to paper money kind of
representing gold to paper money that's
now tied to oil uh ever since the US
brokered a deal with Saudi Arabia to
only sell its oil for US Dollars and
since everyone needs oil that maintained
the US dollar is the reserve currency
and we call this the Petra dollar I
wanted to play a clip from a 2006 Ron
Paul speech on the house floor called
the end of the dollar hemony which you
reference in the book Let's Roll that
clip and I have a question about it for
you after all these many years of great
success our dollar dominance is coming
to an end it has been said rightly that
he who holds the gold makes the rules
that general rule has held fast
throughout the ages when gold was used
in the rules protected honest Commerce
productive Nations Thrive today the
principles are the same but the process
is quite different gold is no longer a
currency of the realm paper is is the
truth now is he who prints the money
makes the rules at least for the time
being although gold is not used the
goals are the same compel foreign
countries to produce and subsidize the
country with military superiority and
control over the monetary printing
presses since printing paper money is
nothing short of counterfeiting the
issuer of the international currency
must always be the country with the
milit might to guarantee control over
the system it is now common knowledge
that the immediate reaction of the
administration after 9/11 revolved
around how they could con uh connect
Saddam Hussein to the
attack to justify an invasion and
overthrow of his government it's not
likely that maintaining dollar Supremacy
was the only motivating factor for the
war against Iraq nor for agitating
against Iran though the real reasons for
going to war are complex we now know the
reasons given before the war started
like the presence of weapons of mass
destruction and Saddam Hussein's
connection to 9/11 were
false what did you find compelling or
Illuminating about this speech so what I
find interesting is that the US has a
pretty aggressive history of going after
countries that um sell oil uh in
non-dollar currencies um you know
there's a lot of dictators in the world
and we don't really uh go after them uh
some of them even do have weapons of
mass destruction to to some some degree
at least and we just don't really do
much other than sanction them and stuff
uh but the ones where we tend to have a
more aggressive role are ones that try
to sell outside of the dollar based
system and so you know on some sense the
dollar Network effect is self-
sustaining I mean when it's tied when
it's tied to the largest economy that
has an open Capital Market um uh it's
got a very large existing debt base
around the world and debt represents
demand for currency it's contractual
demand for currency so you have a built
in inflexible demand Source um these are
all kind of existing Network effect
supports of the dollar but it's they
still feed the network effect from time
to time especially in the 70s is when
they kind of uh kind of resurrected it
from having broken the bretonwood system
and some of these more recent ones the
reason I find this clip interesting is
that it basically shows that the list of
reasons that were given uh to invade
Iraq uh and take some of these other
actions were
unjustified and therefore it basically
argues that it had something to do with
trying to maintain the the existing
money system I also find that clip
interesting you you included some other
parts of it that were not in the quote I
did like the longer basically the longer
version of it and what's interesting is
it shows how powerful Network effects
are because he's talking back in 2006
about um dollar hegemony coming to an
end and here we are uh what is it 17
years later um and it's still it's still
going quite strong we see some you know
fraying around the margins I would argue
uh but it shows that these things move
very slowly um and Ray alio in his his
work a changing World Order actually had
a map that showed different uh kind of
Empires or hedgemont over history and it
was mapping them by different metrics so
you know education quality uh wealth
like um like Eon economic size military
power Reserve currency status all these
different things and what's interesting
is that some of them are leading
indicators and some of them are like
lagging indicators and so for example
education's a leading one uh whereas
Reserve currency is a lagging one in the
sense that it takes longer to get that
Network effect started but then even
when the country starts wanting on
multiple metrics the existing Network
effect of that Reserve currency keeps
persisting for a number of decades
longer before it it also rolls over and
I think that's what we're seeing with
the dollar system now that based on you
know we're no longer the biggest
commodity importer uh we're now rivaled
in some aspects by China um even as
putting China aside if you just look at
Global um percentage of of GDP that the
United States is um we're shrinking but
our dollar percent of that network is
not really shrinking uh and so it's been
disproportionately strong relative to
our economy so I think that's actually
another interesting part of that clip is
just to show that these these things are
not quick changes um but that some of
these decisions to M you know do actions
are very much are likely tied to um the
United States desire to maintain the
global reach that it has with its
currency so that it can sanction any of
these supply lines uh that that it wants
to and so that it it builds in that
monetary premium for its currency by
having every country want to hold you
know as much as possible on their
Reserve balance cheets it also seems
like there's not an obvious successor
right now uh I mean in terms of national
currencies or you know government Fiat
currencies it's not going to I'd be
surprised if we're the Euro um I mean I
know you say China is rising but it's
not I it's hard to imagine that that's
going to replace the US dollar um what
how do you see that shaking out so I
think in general too many people have
recency bias where they assume that the
next system has to look very similar to
the current system so naturally people
are going going around and saying well
what single country's currency could be
the world Reserve currency and then they
right rightfully say Well it can't be
Europe uh too slow growth too fractured
um not energy secure it's not going to
be them then look at China and say while
their demographics are worse um their
geography is not as strong uh they don't
have open Capital controls uh they're
just not a very trusted uh entity on the
global stage um they don't have like the
the language projection that the United
States and English does or the just the
the brand the cultural Network effects
that are established so a lot of people
ready to say there's no other currency
they could just be attain the level of
dominance that the dollar has and my
point is that basically that the idea of
using one country's Ledger as the global
Reserve current curency to tile these
other currencies together is largely an
artifact of the era that we live in
which is this this weird era where we
have fast um payment settlement but not
a fast um like we have fast payment uh
transactions but not fast settlements
and so we've we've relying on
centralization and abstraction one
country's ledger to kind of tie things
together but I think going forward we're
entering a more multi-polar World um
either where you have separate currency
blocks so for example the the wand
becomes the currency of choice in Asia
for example while the the dollar holds
you know much of the the rest of the the
region of the world uh you know
basically split into two or three
different major currency blocks we're
also seeing gold uh a little bit more
emphasized in the core of the system if
you look at brics Nations and you know
bricks and allies they've been not
really accumulating treasuries of the
past decade but they have been
accumulating gold um and so that's been
kind of a a a a preference among a lot
of them and then over time we'll see
what happens with Bitcoin now we have
this kind of distributed Ledger um you
know Rising liquidity Rising security uh
that's you know right now it's still too
small and volatile to play a role for
something like that but we'll see what
it looks like in in 10 years this can be
a settlement Ledger and a savings Ledger
for some of these countries if it
continues to survive various attacks
basically I think that the future world
is is going to be more multi-polar and
based on neutral assets or neutral
settlement pathways
uh versus just one country hedgemon
running everything I think that's that
was inherently an un unsustainable
situation I mean basically when the
United States founded this we were over
40% of global GDP we were like last
person standing last country standing in
World War II um we had all the gold
basically like not only do we have a lot
of gold ourselves but like other
countries even put their gold with us
for
safekeeping best geography uh we had a
strong manufacturing base we were we
were still a surplus Nation at the time
now we're a deficit Nation so in
multiple metrics there's really no
country big enough to be the only
Reserve currency issuer including
ironically the United States now uh so
it's not it's not the EU uh it's not uh
China and it's it's arguably not even
the United States and I want to get to
Bitcoin in a few minutes but first just
to linger on our current situation a
little bit longer where we've got the
basically the Petra dollar system you
have a number of critiques of it both in
the way that it affects developing
countries and also us here in the United
States what are the biggest problems
with our current system from your point
of view so if you look at the
perspective of a developing country the
one of the challenges if you if you list
out how many developing countries have
developed in the past 50 years um it's
arguably Singapore because the funny
thing is f uh FTS and msci they don't
even count Taiwan and South Korea as
developed although I I will say that
they are I mean if if a country has
better internet then I have I consider
them developed but uh so if we include
some of them that are kind of uh gry
Zone developed uh I fully consider them
developed but it's it's still you can
count on one hand the number of
countries that went from developing to
developed there's even a handful of
countries that went backwards um during
this era and before like Argentina
arguably you know you were one of the
wealthiest countries in the world and
you you kind of gradually SL slide back
into developing country status if you
look at it financially there's one
metric that really kind of defines
whether countries developed or
developing in the modern era and that is
basically whether or not their most of
their debt is denominated in their own
currency or not um there's other metrics
of course like uh you know overall GDP
per capita that that's really what we
think of but in terms of the monetary
system what makes a European country or
America or Canada or Australia or Japan
what makes them different than the
Brazil's of the world or the south
africas of the world or other countries
like that is that those developing
countries nobody really wants to lend to
them in their own currency and so they
lend to them in dollars or Euros usually
dollars um and so these countries have
dollar denominated debt and the
challenge there is that any time the
United States can Harden uh that debt
they can just Jack rates from zero to 6%
and and do quantitative tightening and
just kind of basically try to break that
country and and uh damage them and then
get concessions from them uh you know to
to do various things or if there's a lot
of other countries that are saving in
treasuries you know they they build up
huge trade surpluses uh we can devalue
them we can kind of rug pole uh the
savings uh if we find that it's in the
United States best interest and so we
kind of push a lot of this volatility
out into the rest of the world um and we
look around the world kind of if I
describe in one kind of phrasing why
money's broken is that there's 60
different plus currencies in the world
each of them is this little currency
bubble most of them have virtually no
currency exceptions outside of their own
country like if you know if if I have
Egyptian pounds with me in New Jersey
there's there's it'd be very hard to get
them off my hands and anything
resembling a reasonable exchange rate
just because you know it's they're just
completely
unsalable and so people are stuck in
these currency Bubbles and for example
in Egypt money supply is growing by 20%
a year right so you're on this rapid
treadmill Tri trying to uh increase your
wages to not get diluted you're trying
to do something with your savings to not
get it devalued you're sticking it into
like an extra property that you just
leave empty because what else are you
going to do with it you're stacking I
know a physician in Egypt that really
Stacks physical cash dollars that he
gets from the gray market and that's in
the 21st century that's what he's doing
for his savings and so that's kind of
the environment that a lot of these
developing countries find themselves in
uh and in contrast the the downside for
American americ perspective is that in
order to supply the world with a reserve
currency there's only a few mechanisms
that we get out and the primary method
that we do is structural trade
deficits and this is this part of the
system kind of does it to itself it's
automatic because so many entities
around the world want to hold uh dollars
and so that gives them a premium above
what they would normally trade at in
order to have somewhat balanced trade um
and so it basically makes American
Import power stronger than it otherwise
would be and it makes our export
competitiveness for for lower marger
margin things uh not very competitive uh
and so we we kind of cracked open the
structural trade deficit that never
really resolves and that starts
hollowing out the country's industrial
base uh that contributes to political
polarization wealth concentration
because if you if you work in New York
if you're basically if you're in New
York DC or you work in intellectual
property you know Tech Healthcare high
margin stuff like that those areas
you're really benefiting from the system
but if you're anything Rel to basic Blue
Collar manufacturing stuff like that
this system has been kind of um
weaponized against them we've in order
to have the system we basically shipped
our industrial base gradually piece by
piece to the rest of the world on this
question of trade deficits and this
chart is from your book that I pulled up
a second ago showing the US trade
balance since the 1974 Petro dollar
agreement obviously line go down there
um what uh is you know you make the
point in the book that trade deficits on
their own in a free market are not
always a bad thing that might be a um it
that it might just be a example of a
strong um currency uh and other other
countries developing certain
manufacturing
capabilities how does uh and you
describe the US as kind of a a boxer who
can't feel pain um could you just expand
on that that metaphor a lot because that
helped me really understand the the
point you were getting at sure so
basically trade deficits as you point
out aren't aren't necessarily an issue I
mean I Ed the example in the book if if
Brazil's developing and so they import a
lot of um equipment from Japan and they
run a trade deficit for a number of
years but then they use that eventually
more productively to basically increase
their commodity exports and recoup some
of that for example that that can be
it's not like every single year we have
to worry if a country has a trade
deficit but what does become an issue is
is if you have a like an artificial
trade deficit because there's some sort
of top- down force on it that's that's
disturbing markets and in this case uh
the basically the kind of the the reach
of the American Empire or the network
effects that we've established uh give
this kind of constant bid for the dollar
that is largely unrelated to the
American trade deficit so normally a
country if you run a trade deficit for
too long you're you're going to correct
in one of multiple ways it was different
under a gold standard in in the current
Fe currency system it's mostly because
your currency is eventually going to
have a probably significant devaluation
so your import power is going to be
harmed and your uh export
competitiveness is going to uh be be
stronger and it's going to kind of you
know so usually painfully but it's going
to likely um uh kind of recoup itself uh
whereas the dollar is basically
prevented from ever doing that or at
least for for multiple decades at a time
when it hits a point where most
countries would would would probably go
through a devaluation and reset their
trade balance to some extent basically
make it more competitive just to bring
manufacturing back to the US uh or to
reduce you know our ability to keep
importing things uh that just doesn't
really happen because of the system we
have now
and the result and at first it sounds
good to people because you think okay if
we can just give pieces of paper and we
can get real goods and services that
sounds like it's an our advantage and of
course the for some entities in the
system that is a big Advantage the
downside is to keep in mind step two
which is go those countries can take
those paper currencies and of course
really they're mostly digital ledgers at
this point but they can take those
currencies and then they buy American
Capital assets they buy it used to be
you know basically becoming a creditor
so they would own treasury security and
things like that now they increasingly
own equities uh real estate private
Equity um they they basically reinvest
their trade surpluses into owning bigger
and bigger percentages of American
productive capacity and eventually you
get to a really weird point where the
foreign sector owns a very significant
amount of the properties here and then
part of the reason we see so much things
like swap lines and other other kind of
Central Bank alphabet soup programs
whenever there's a crisis is because the
system has become so
imbalanced that whenever we have a
recession if the dollar gets stronger
all of these dollar D debts around the
world Harden and what some of these
countries do is they start selling some
of the assets they've accumulated and
that can do things like freeze up our
treasury market break our treasury
market uh and cause all these issues so
basically the the hollowing out effect
and the ability and the ability to kind
of sustain that holl out for more
decades than most other countries can
make it so that whenever we do feel this
like whenever the world does change
enough that the US dollar monetary
premium goes away maybe we enter more
multi-polar world or something like
that we are kind of left holding a bag
of having exported a large Port portion
of our industrial base and then kind of
getting hit with that sort of all at
once Ju Just to pull up another chart
from your book that illustrates this
point this is the US annual industrial
production per capita 1920 to 2022
normalized to 100 in the year
2000 um you know you say that the
manufacturing base in America has been
hollowed out I mean I see mostly an
upward line and then sort of flattening
around the year 2000 uh after after a
dip or and and then a dip what is
concerning to you about this chart uh
that that chart itself I think
understates the problem it just shows I
use that chart to show the abruptness of
the trend change you have eight decades
up and then two decades um you know flat
to down um when you look at things like
the net International Investment
position and things like that that's
where you get the the more concerning
looking picture it's basically the the
the spillover is the fact that a lot of
this is cumulative so every year that we
run trade deficits year after year
decade after decade these start
compiling into foreign creditor Nation
hands and then they start having
significant sway over um you know our
our assets even our companies um and I
think that's it's it's it's just not
healthy and then when we see Rising
political
polarization uh a lot of it is tied to
that hollowing out aspect um and you
know it's not as though this just
happened with natural market forces this
happened because of some geopolitical
strategic decisions on basically how to
use the C currency basically the the
currencies instead of being this open
trade environment it's like there's
these different currency bubbles that
kind of EB and flow relative to each
other and those can create these
distortions and so you basically have
this this centralized issue you have an
opposite problem when a currency a
country is like a mercantilist model and
they keep artificially devaluing their
currency China for instance right that
that be China what what you get there is
that people's wages rise more slowly
than they otherwise would uh basically
their currency is not as not hardening
as as strong as you'd expect it to and
instead the country is printing a lot
more currency so they can buy reserves
and a lot of that wealth gets stored up
at The Sovereign level uh and and and
redeployed rather than letting that
settle uh that wealth accumulate among
the private sector and so different
imbalances can be made when you have
centralized kind of currency management
uh decisions at these big scales and you
know you're arguing in a sense that the
US needs to move Beyond this Petra
dollar system and and give up Reserve
status or that we it's not even really
going to be a choice they might lose
Reserve status what would happen
to just average Americans if the US gave
up or lost Reserve currency status so
the way I describe it I think is that
basically the benefits from having the
reserve currency status are pretty
linear so they're about the same now as
they were 50 years ago whereas the costs
of maintaining the system get a little
bit more every year uh and So eventually
you know that hollowing out becomes a
bigger downside than the upsides we get
from it uh that that's how I think that
how this goes it's basically like we're
we're holding this heavy weight and
we're getting benefits from it but we're
slowly getting you know tired out from
from being able to do that um and it's
not that I think the US should purposely
give it up it's that I think that the
problem is that
countries often assume that if they
start losing it they have to keep
fighting to keep it and that's the
dangerous part because if we if we use a
lot of resources to keep a system that
we're not even really benefiting by on
net anymore that's where you get
disaster instead if you recognize the
problem and kind of let that change more
gracefully um then you can come out of
it stronger and it can be painful for a
period of time but you can you can use
that to accelerate and get the get the
most out of it um probably the biggest
downside we'd see in in that kind of
more multi-polar world is that the US
would one buy have higher inflation than
we otherwise would in in this system but
two uh the upside is that we we could
have a period of renewal for our
industrial base basically to as long as
we hold together as a society and and
maintain good rule of law and and you
know are are attractive at at you know
enticing capital and respecting capital
and deploying that um that can fix this
kind of structural trade balance and and
and bring things back um there's also I
the the the bigger things that are kind
of drawn down by it are things that most
Americans don't care about like for
example uh the global Military reach of
the United States would be impaired if
it was no longer the global Reserve
currency status and that's why in the
book I kind of separate America the
Empire versus America the country
because you talk about what is good for
America it's very different to depending
on what perspective you're talking about
if you're if you're talking about what
what would the what would the Pentagon
want um versus what what does a uh you
know a plumber want for example or what
is a what is a manufacturer of you know
um widgets want right so so different um
outcomes affect different groups
differently but I think the main issues
is basically that if we if if resources
are expanded to fight for a system that
is no longer benefiting from us that's
how we get things like the the war in
Iraq that that's how we get kind of
these disastrous loss of blood and
treasure um that don't really go
anywhere the if we look a little more
closely at our current political and
fiscal situation you know the FED we we
had the the coid shock we had all the
debt that accumulated during that the
FED hiked interest rates to try to tame
inflation after all the the the checks
went out and and and the money went out
and this last year resulted in a testy
exchange between fed chairman Jerome
Powell and Senator Elizabeth Warren
which you also referenced in your book
Let's Roll that clip for a
moment last week you announced that the
FED would raise rates by three4 of a
percentage point the biggest increase in
nearly 30 years so let's talk about what
the FED is and isn't doing when it
raises interest rates to try to bring
down inflation let's start with gas
prices the price of gas is up 40% since
Russia invaded Ukraine in February chair
pal will gas prices go down as a result
of your interest rate increase I would
not think so now rate increases make it
more likely that companies will fire
people and slash hours to shrink wage
costs rate increases also make it more
expensive for families to do things
things like borrow money for a house and
so far the cost this year of a mortgage
has already doubled uh inflation is like
an illness and Medicine needs to be
tailored to the specific problem
otherwise you could make things a lot
worse and right now the FED has no
control over the main drivers of rising
prices but the FED can slow Demand by
getting a lot of people fired and making
families poorer and while President
Biden is working to increase energy
supplies and straighten out supply chain
Kinks and break up monopolies and bring
down prices you could actually tip this
economy into recession so I just want to
say you know what's worse than high
inflation and low unemployment it's high
inflation and a recession with millions
of people out of work and I hope you'll
reconsider
that so it's worth noting that we have
not entered a recession and un
employment is still under 4% is that
evidence that pal actually is steering
the ship somewhat
competently I think the overall
challenge right now is that this the
inflation we're seeing now is fiscal
driven inflation um so you you look back
over time at the at the inflationary
periods and the sources of money
creation um they can be very different
and so the 70s that was a demographics
bulge um and so you had a lot of credit
creation a lot of Bank lending d in
money supply growth that was actually
bigger than the deficits we were running
at the time whereas the 1940s for
example that inflationary period was
because of tons of money printing for
the war and so far what we've seen in
the 2020s is is the the second type
we've seen very fiscal driven inflation
not excessive Bank lending uh but the
Federal Reserve tools are exclusively
designed to deal with uh either trying
to accelerate Bank lending or slow down
Bank lending as well as things like
control the wealth effect and things
like that they're not really designed at
all to deal with fiscal driven inflation
the best they can do with fiscal driven
inflation is try to slow down private
sector stuff so that it offsets the the
fiscal side um and so what we're seeing
now is that the FED is harming certain
industries for example banking
system um you know commercial real
estate arguably a lot of this does need
to be cleaned out the challenge is
they're also blowing out the fiscal
deficit with higher interest expense
which you know in the 70s didn't matter
because we had 30% that the GDP but now
that we have 120% that the GDP uh you
actually it becomes weird because the
effect from um you know that the
inflationary effect from those larger
deficits from the higher interest
expense can actually offset some of the
Slowdown you get in the private sector
from trying to sque squeeze those so I
think since then we've been stuck in
this limbo um Senator uh Warren's
concerns uh appear not to have
materialized but the the reason I bring
up the clip in that book is not to
predict a recession uh because the
book's meant to be you know read for for
many years not really kind of talking
about what's going to happen next year
the reason I bring it up is to show kind
of the somewhat cartoonish nature of the
fed's tools in either direction
basically if they're trying to slow down
inflation they're literally trying to
increase unemployment levels uh and and
hurt the wealth effect and uh you know
it's kind of a funny thing for what is
basically the fourth branch of
government to try to be do on the other
hand when uh we're in a recession and
inflation's low or sometimes even
negative they they specifically want to
debase currency debase savings debase
wages uh to try to re accelerate more
debt growth as though that's you know
because it you know it's it's shorttime
preference thinking it says okay more
debt can get us out of this recession
but then okay what happens when you just
keep accumulating debt you know
recession after recession decade after
decade and so the the FED has these very
blunt tools um that are just very
powerful for centralized entity to have
like we wouldn't want um some sort of
central agency determining the price of
beef um or a bunch of other things let
alone the price of money itself the
price of credit uh arguably the most
important price of all and yet that's
the the system we have right now and
it's a very kind of um
manual kind of um they have models to
guide them but at the end of the day
it's basically 12 people in a room
deciding what the price of money is yeah
you draw a real contrast between how you
think about prices which is a framework
that's more in line with someone like fa
hyek then do our Central Bankers uh what
is the main difference there
between how you think about prices and
the function that they are supposed to
play and Jerome pal or anyone else in
the what you call the fourth branch of
government so I think there's two layers
there one is that when haek refer to
pricing and that that's what he's most
well known for is that he focused on
pricing as a signaling mechanism uh that
basically it's a it's a more efficient
way to coordinate uh the production
distribution uh and consumption of goods
and services um than Central committies
because the just the the amount of
bandwidth and decision points that are
being done uh goes above anything you
can do with a kind of a central steering
committee um the other layer to that is
kind of this unintuitive notion that the
bank is really trying to like you know
kind of push back the tide which is
basically that over in a functioning
Society um we should be making some
nonzero progress towards better
productivity better technology and so
around the margins things should
generally get cheaper each year or at
least certain things should get cheaper
incrementally and on average uh after in
any kind of multi-year period prices
should generally be going down unless
there's a war or some other shortage
problem that that pushes prices up but
central banks even though that's that's
like the defining force of what prices
themselves should do central banks by
their mandates want to override that
they want to have positive 2% price
increases so even though things are
easier to produce they want them to get
more expensive every year it's kind of a
like a sfist rolling the the rock up a
hill it's it's like this this constant
effort and the challenge there is that
they're not working at 0% inflation
they're working against negative
inflation and so you know they have to
increase they have to have money supply
go up by five six
s% in order to hit their you know their
CPI targets and when that happens we
don't get prices going up um in like a
uniform way you have things like
software is still getting cheaper um you
know Electronics get cheaper but things
you know that are actually energy
intensive or labor intensive like beef
and oil and house prices and stuff like
that that tends to go quicker on average
over the long term than
CPI because of this kind of constant
monetary dilution effect and kind of
what I referenced in the book is that
you know kind of like how blood letting
used to just be this like very common
medical tool it was just kind of assumed
that if someone has a fever this is what
we do and of course now with better
knowledge we know that outside of
certain conditions it's it's not helpful
um and I think that this era is going to
be looked back on in kind of an
interesting ways like the that Central
Bankers were purposely trying to always
smoothly grow the prices of things that
are actually should be getting cheaper
it's kind of just a remarkable way that
we handle things now so the premise of
what they're doing from my understanding
is that there there's a worry that uh if
we're in this world where prices are
actually going down all the time that
this makes you more prone to what they
call liquidity traps where people are
just holding on or people are hoarding
their money because they just are
waiting for the prices to continually go
down and then we get a real stagnant
economy is that a is there something
wrong with that way of thinking about it
yeah I think that the technology sector
shows that to be untrue uh people get
you know Apple's the most valuable
company in the world even though they
sell a deflationary product every year
their phone gets a little bit better uh
especially on a on a per dollar basis
and people don't just say well I'm gonna
wait seven years to get a phone
um you know sometimes you might push it
out three months to get the next model
if there's a model coming up um but you
know people need a phone and so they go
out and get a phone people need a
computer they need a car they want to
live their life they want to eat at
restaurant they want to cook at home
they want to have a house um and so
there's really no evidence like L the
most
valuable uh sector in the world is the
most deflationary one we also can look
at time periods like the you know the
second half of the 1800s uh in the
United States in Britain this this was a
golden age of innovation and and real
economic growth even though we had
pretty long stretches of outright
deflation um and so I think that's
that's kind of proven not to be the case
I think the real reason that they don't
like deflation is because uh the one
thing it is compat like not compatible
with is tremendous amounts of debt and
so they're their models based on having
a very highly levered system and if you
ever get kind of broad deflation those
liabilities start getting harder uh
basically our our system only works when
those liabilities are kind of constantly
growing and constantly getting mildly
diluted I I think that's ultimately the
real reason that's why when people hear
deflation they assume it's a bad thing
they think of recessions uh because
that's in the modern context the only
time we ever really see it whereas
structural deflation is good we we like
the fact that TVs and computers and
phones are structurally cheaper now uh
especially on a on a on a p quality
basis than they were five years ago 10
years ago 20 years ago um and basically
the idea that we have to centrally
through Central decision- making keep
people on a constant treadmill of
consumption by discouraging their
savings uh and trying to get them to to
go consume faster I just think it's very
misguided
policy what uh you know people can and
should subscribe to your newsletter if
they want detailed investment advice but
you know for an individual just trying
to save money for retirement not get
wiped out by all these centralized
forces beyond their control can you
offer some general rules of the road or
things to look out for in the
environment when deciding what to
do so generally you know in this
environment where money's weak we
monetize other things um and so rather
than investment being an optional thing
that we engage in it becomes a pretty
necessary thing that we engage in um and
so that can include obviously equities
it can include real estate it can
include just scarce things like gold um
or land uh stuff like that and of course
the problem there is that all those
things have various degrees of
inefficiencies right they if it's land
or real estate they might be IL liquid
um if we buy something and hold it and
then sell something we pay capital gains
taxes on it uh so we're basically
getting tax not just on the real growth
but on the my apologies so we're getting
taxed on the dilution itself uh along
the way because we have these
non-adjusted um capital gains Taxation
and so basically people have to hold
their assets and other things at least
as long as we live in this world of you
know kind of a a constant currency uh de
basement and it's more challenging so in
the United States it's easier because we
have some of the the strongest Capital
markets in the world um but it's harder
if you're in other countries for example
in Egypt the stock market is is not just
up into the right uh especially in like
International purchasing power terms um
and so instead you have a very volatile
and generally underperforming market so
not not a lot of people just naturally
you know put put savings into the stock
market every week like we do in the
United States and so instead they often
buy things like second homes or ex you
know add another uh layer to their home
or again hold like physical cash dollars
under their mattress or buy gold for
example there's many markets where it's
hard to do something but in general you
want to hold scarce things and you want
to hold things where it's your share of
that thing is not getting diluted very
rapidly well I think that might bring us
to the final section of your book which
is about the rise of Bitcoin we are just
today uh hitting the 15-year Mark of the
white paper that launched Bitcoin um and
in a return to your technological
determinism you say that it's solved a
problem technologically that no other
money in history has managed to what is
that problem and how did Bitcoin solve
it so it's the first credible technology
that lets us send value uh quickly in
long distances without using credit um
and so it's it's the it's the first time
we can do uh final kind of bear asset
settlements uh quickly um and so it kind
of solves this this Gap we've been in so
prior to the telegraph uh transactions
information matter that that all moved
at roughly the same speed in order order
to transact with someone you had to go
on a horse or a boat and go out and and
you know spread that information and
come back with it uh with the telegraph
you know especially when they were
deployed in the second half of the 19th
century that changed we now were able to
to enter this kind of new centry and a
half period where we can we can transact
very quickly but we can't settle very
quickly and so our ledgers become very
abstract and centralized and by
extension they became corrupted
inflationary uh to varing degrees you
know the Dollar's workable St whereas if
you're in Argentina you're having a
rough time right now uh with their
Ledger and of course there's a big
Spectrum in between um and what Bitcoin
does is it's the first way to say well
here's a ledger that's
decentralized and you can basically send
units to another address in a way that's
not based on someone's IOU it's not
reversible unless of course you know
miners were to collude or someone were
to capture half the network and then
structurally start censoring it
reversing
over time and that of course takes a ton
of energy and supply chain stuff and all
all that kind of thing so it's actually
barring those edge cases this is now a
network for fast almost real time final
settlement which which closes that speed
Gap and
allows um longdistance money transfer
and longdistance efficient you know kind
of monetary communication to happen
without credit or with much uh smaller
amounts of of credit in the system the
other thing that it does is it it
pierces these 160 different currency
bubbles uh and so it it used to be the
case you know where the really the only
two ways to get money in or out of a
country is either one physical ports of
entry and of course they have that
heavily surveil you can only bring so
much cash or gold with you through an
airport uh the other way would be Bank
transfers which are also very heavily
controlled and so countries can make it
hard for their citizens to get things
like cash or gold and they can basically
force their local currency Monopoly uh
with a lot of frictions to escape it uh
but what Bitcoin does and to some extent
what stable coins do is they they just
it's like a machine gun they just like
put a ton of holes uh through that whole
perimeter it's just completely porous
now where you can like you can send
money with a QR code over a video call
you can send money with an email a DM
anytime there's two Internet connected
entities they can now send um
peer-to-peer value through this network
that goes around that country local
banking system in addition the value
density is unlimited so for example you
can memorize 12 words representing your
Bitcoin you know private key and you
could you could go through an airport
with a billion dollars worth of it um
million dollars worth of It Whatever the
the number you have it's it's impossible
to prove that you have or do not have it
uh you could write it down there's
multiple ways to do it and so basically
that starts breaking these
monopolies um if the liquidity and
recognition of it becomes significant
and I think that really so bitcoin's 15
years old it's really only been five or
six years where it's had enough
liquidity and kind of public awareness
um stable coins too only only really the
past few years has their liquidity been
very big and so this is just kind of
like a a new kind of era for monetary
technology that really starts especially
pressuring the weaker ledgers so the
Argentinas of the world uh all the
people there now have a lot more tools
to get their hands on on better monies
either by holding dollar
you know stable coin is kind of like a
offshore bank account for the middle
class uh it's centralized it's it's it's
still devaluing with the rate of the
dollar but if you're in Argentina you
might say well I want to hold some
dollars and stable coins give me an
easier way to access that than physical
dollars in the gray Market um and of
course bitcoin's even even you know a
different kind of Beast all together
yeah it if it combines those aspects of
gold where it cannot be devalued at at
will uh and the speed of Fiat the
concern that I have with its future is
that the US government banned gold
ownership for four decades because of it
it being a threat to the US dollar How
concerned are you that if Bitcoin ever
presented a real threat
to the US dollar that it would suffer
the same fate so I think on on in
general holding back technology is very
hard to do um the United States and
China are really the entities that have
a lot of Firepower to cause Bitcoin um
challenges one thing to keep in mind is
that um the gold ban uh in the FDR days
was in an environment of super political
concentration so his party had like 70%
uh of of Congress for example and so you
could you could stack the courts you
could you could override you could you
could just do super majority stuff um
and that's not the world we have today
so I think that basically yes if we were
to have a super majority of government
that does not like Bitcoin uh that
really could set back Bitcoin for for
quite a while uh it could damage the
liquidity of the network uh it could it
could force uh institutional investors
to uh discourage it it it could render
it on to the the gray Market or black
market uh and of course there still be
foreign usage of it there's plenty of
hubs around the world that would happily
say Okay build your companies here and
it's it's free to use here but it would
damage liquidity but I think that those
types of draconian things are harder to
do if there's not that kind of super
majority concentration of power it's
also why I do think that some political
works useful I mean I'm not I'm not
really politically engaged but there are
other people that go out and uh you know
talk to senators and congressmen and
make sure they understand it I mean
during this recent uh multi-week period
where there was no speaker in the house
the acting speaker the house um he he's
hosting the Bitcoin white paper on
congress's website and so the acting
speaker of the house and you know for
now he's it's still there he's not the
acting speaker anymore but he's still
you know Congress is hosting the white
paper um and and that's that's the world
we live in where there are Senators that
like it there are Congress people that
like it um there are there are Governors
that like it there are presidential
candidates that like it and we also have
a somewhat independent Judiciary and
rule of law and you can point to things
like the First Amendment the Fourth
Amendment and there's context in that
where for example in the 1990s Phil
Zimmerman um got in legal trouble for
introducing open source encryption to
the world and uh the US went after him
but they they eventually lost because
they couldn't get past the First
Amendment once he published the code in
a book uh and I think that Bitcoin has
similar methods to try to protect itself
from the most Draconian um push back so
what might a transition to a more
Bitcoin based monetary system look like
like what are the main technical
obstacles that need to be overcome to
really get that that widespread adoption
because it seems like right now what you
were saying is that stable coins are the
big thing that uh people in countries
with a weak currency are adopting a
stable coin just for anyone listening
who doesn't know it's basically a
cryptographic token that is redeemable
for a national currency like a US dollar
so in a sense people are still hungry
for US Dollars what would have to change
for that hunger to turn to
bitcoin I think a lot of it is just
liquidity uh and so when Bitcoin traded
,000 dollar a day uh a millionaire
couldn't just go in and put a million
dollars into without moving the price
that the overall liquidity and
salability were low when Bitcoin traded
Millions a day someone couldn't just
come and put a billion into it um
without moving the price and even today
when it trades billions of dollars per
day um uh you know they're very large
pools of capital that that if they're
not careful they can move the price it's
just not it's not a big liquid enough
market for them to really kind of um go
in significantly it's still not doesn't
have enough money properties for them
yet it has money properties at lower
levels but the the bigger you get the
less liquid it is and so it's still a
tiny fraction of the overall dollar
monetary system which is much bigger
much more liquid uh much more entrenched
Network effect so I think that
part of it is just going through a
handful of more Cycles I mean it has the
benefit of absolute scarcity so it's
growing at a lower rate uh in addition
developers keep building on top of it so
there's more layers uh so they can be
using it there are better wallets better
user experience um part of what um you
know I originally discovered Bitcoin in
like 2010 or so and it's one of those
things where in order to get it you had
to like mine it and then like I would
Revisited a couple years later like I
didn't buy any or didn't didn't acquire
any I and I would kind of look at the
exchanges and they'd be really sketchy
looking and you had to like wire money
to like you know Japan and then like you
it's like this whole thing and then of
course it became much easier to do it
and then the wallet technology became
much easier to use and so part of it is
just the ux gets better over time
liquidity gets better over time and then
of course every year that goes by people
try to find more ways to break it or
centralize it things like that so it's
kind of like it's being tested for its
hardness you know can someone find a way
to you know break the overall technical
capabilities of the Bitcoin Network and
every year that goes by where that
doesn't happen the the Lindy effect on
it is
strengthening um unlike most
technologies that can be adopted very
quickly and smoothly so you know most
Technologies you adopt like the
smartphone you never go back to to not
having a smartphone you don't adopt
electricity and they go back to not
having it a new monetary technolog is
different because unlike those uh it can
be levered uh and so if it starts to go
up in a smooth pattern people will
realize that and leverage it and then
they will make it a bubble and it'll
crash and then people will actually
deopt it they'll be like well I I messed
up I shouldn't have bought Bitcoin it's
a scam and they they get out and then
Bitcoin has to spend a few years
rebuilding from people that actually you
know deeply followed the the network and
understand what's going on there and say
okay there was a there was a local
bubble and it's going to work itself out
and then they kind of re reome into the
network on the next cycle so by its very
nature it's going to adopt basically a
cyclical and longer taking way and I
think really start to challenge dollar
one of two ways either just the sheer
liquidity and size of the network
eventually reduces the volatility of it
you know if it's held by um just you
know billion people around the world in
in some small way that's less volatile
Network than one where you know some
like guy with crazy hair in the in the
Bahamas can like you know manipulate the
price it just gets harder um and and two
um uh the United States dollar does have
some kind of long-term fiscal challenges
with it now uh that we've not really
seen in a very very long time um and So
eventually the dollar can enter a more
structurally inflationary uh problematic
period um kind of like what Japan would
look like if Japan had a trade deficit
uh and had these other kind of
challenges and so I do think that either
the dollar can hurt itself or Bitcoin
can just keep Gathering liquidity and
techical proof and and and just overall
better ux assuming again that nothing no
one finds a way to hack it centralize it
censor it or otherwise disrupt it right
it it's pumped a bit lately on news that
major firms like Black Rock are pursuing
approval of a Bitcoin ETF how
significant do you think that is uh in
bitcoin's trajectory to have that kind
of possible institutional adoption and
acquisition so there's tens of trillions
of dollars worth of like ra Capital that
um doesn't really go into the into
Bitcoin like it's not it's not normal to
hold it as part of a portfolio some of
them are not like some advisors not
allowed to uh give it to their clients
other ones are it depends on their on
what network they operate in and uh
Black Rock the world's biggest asset
manager um making ETF and then having
the SEC approve uh the ETF would be a
really big signal for some that's kind
of the some some non nonzero amount of
that Capital could eventually find its
way into Bitcoin so I do think that
overall these these things that make it
easier to hold in brokerage environments
or you know just managed assets uh where
a lot of capital is um are useful uh and
it allows basically larger portfolio
types or more existing portfolios to
hold it in in a way um I think that to
the extent that Bitcoin is going to keep
monetizing these types of steps are
inevitable um this is like the step
where for example like I said before
when it traded millions of dollars worth
of volume a day a billion couldn't
really ape into it uh now that it's at
billions of dollars a day in order to
attract these biggest pools of capital
like gigantic pensions or Sovereign
wealth funds or central bank balance
sheets it really has to kind of tanax to
another level of liquidity if not more
uh and so the these kind of
institutional steps along the way I
think are kind of the next phase um and
it's also it's it's harder to that
that's kind of
growing kind of defense against Bitcoin
ever being like outright banned in the
US because you you have more legal
precedent legal momentum people that own
it people that don't want it to be
banned people that like it uh both among
the public and people in positions of
power uh and when you combine that with
rule of law and government officials
themselves in many cases liking Bitcoin
it just helps that asset entrench itself
and remove some of the tail risk of you
know other challenges so lastly you have
in mind something like a Bitcoin future
for if if money is broken that's one of
the potential fix is something more
market-based that incentivizes saving
rather than debt the other vision of the
future is something of of our money's
future is something like cbdc Central
Bank digital currencies you describe
this as a surveillance and control
mindset that is gripping much of our
ruling class can you sketch out
what that Vision might look like and why
it's something best
avoided so over the past Century and a
half and really more than that most
efficiencies we make with money come at
the cost of centralization and more
surveillance um so we make money faster
and easier but it gets coalescent to
bank Banks and then central banks and
Central Bank digital currencies are kind
of like the the Capstone of that where
it's just fully surveilled it's kind of
fully locked in it's programmable by the
the state um privacy is basically just
completely lost at that point um and
so in that world it kind of helps
maintain the 160 different currency
bubbles that that countries have now it
makes it hard to for people to kind of
Escape that system now luckily in a
world where Bitcoin and stable coins
exist um countries you know assets can
now Pierce each other's borders which
are hard to stop um you know stable
coins the United States could stop
easily but the question is do they want
to and and certainly the Argentinas or
the nigerias of the world can't do
anything about the fact that stable
coins exist Bitcoin can potentially
disrupt even the biggest currencies in
the long Arc of time and and so we'll
see how if it's up to that challenge um
but basically we we have one of two
directions either we can Embrace some of
the open source technology and allow
more market-based
competition and it's not NE necessarily
a choice it's I think there's some
degree of technological determinism in
the sense that if this technology is
robust enough and desirable enough it's
very hard to overwhelm the market forces
of people that would want these
Technologies um but if whatever reason
if the technology insufficient or if
it's kind of like killed in the Cradle
before it can really kind of fully
mature uh or set back a long period of
time one way or another um then we enter
a world of you know more centralized
control than we've been accustomed to
too and then you can you know things
like you can use narratives around War
you can use narratives around um the
environment things like that to control
how people spend more on a regular basis
which is a a somewhat dystopian future
and it it's not hard to imagine that
more places could be kind of like
direction that China goes in which is to
have a pretty significant top- down uh
enforcement and I think that should be
generally resisted uh and that that
freedom of being able to use whatever
money
you want basically freedom to protect
your own savings your own accumulated
time and energy uh uh should be rewarded
and I think it's useful for people to
understand these Technologies either
potentially to use them themselves or to
understand just the macro context what
what the existence of these things mean
so if if things like Bitcoin and stable
coins can Pierce Financial borders in a
way that hasn't been useful hasn't been
possible before what does that mean for
you know different countries in their
ability to maintain currencies what does
it mean for glob assets I think these
are questions that investors and just
anyone kind of interested in the subject
should be familiar with but I mean
there's a there's a movement against
cbdcs against Central Bank digital
currencies but I'm not sure that the
average listener or American exactly
understands what it is how it's
different than just dollars being
digital there's you know a programmable
aspect to CBD CES and that is the really
dangerous privacy violating part could
you just give a couple examples of why
from your perspective that would be an
assault on Liberty so it used to be that
transactions were naturally private like
handing over a bank note or gold coin or
silver coin was a private act uh but but
as things kind of coess onto bank
balance sheets uh we we and then there's
like various laws that make those Banks
constantly give over the information to
the government we we kind of the the
natural Assumption of what is normal has
shifted kind of to be an anti-privacy
stance and cash is kind of the last
vestage of privacy um and of course it's
it's fairly controlled I mean try to go
to your bank and if you got $100,000 in
the account be like yeah I'd like to
take that out uh it's my money um you're
going to get a lot of push back uh
trying to take out very large amounts of
cash from the system because it's
generally discouraged um and because
they don't like that much private value
going around even in some countries
buying above a little bit of gold gets
you basically kyc like uh you get you
get identified for having done that um
and so there's a lot of um and I think
this is like to the extent that they
attack Bitcoin I don't think it'll be
about things like Banning it it it be
about things like Banning the private
usage of it or putting restrictions on
self- cussing it saying oh just just
hold it in the Black Rock ETF you know
just fully fully put in these silos
don't hold it yourself that's that's
that's kind of the push back back I
think it's going to happen yeah they're
already saying that it was used to fund
Hamas without any evidence whatsoever
that that was a significant source of
Revenue that that's always seems to be
the vector of attack is like you know
the terrorists the bad people use it um
so you know maybe uh a good way to close
this would just uh if you will make the
case for even if bad people use things
sometimes why is it valuable to have
private censorship resist in money yeah
it's good so an example I use in the
book is that uh in the 1980s when when
Pages were becoming a thing um they were
often used by drug dealers to basically
signal each other um and of course
people were freaking out about this
usage of it even though they had
legitimate uses by all all manner of
people that that needed rapid alerts for
them and there were like serious
discussions around how can we restrict
this technology so only the good people
have it which is kind of laughable today
because everybody has smartphones now
it's a it's 100 times more powerful than
a pager and we were worried about people
having pagers if they were bad people um
basically any sufficiently powerful
technology gets used used by good people
and bad people like luckily most people
are good um and you know the the for
example the human rights Foundation uh
is a an organization that kind of um
kind of pushes back against
authoritarianism around the world um
people that are in particularly unfree
countries uh and supports you know
democracy Advocates or just fre people
that that that yearn for freedom and and
Liberty and just human rights in general
and they find things like Bitcoin and
stable coin to be very powerful so all
you'd have to imagine is for your
politician that you don't like having
control over your money to be able to
see all that you do uh to be to program
uh transactions that don't kind of
conform to how they think you should be
spending your money I think basically
there's a level of control that's
inappropriate for governments to have I
think that and that I think the case can
be made for people across the political
Spectrum uh whether or not someone's
like a a a significant libertarian or
someone thinks that there's a pretty
significant role of government in in
their environment I think it's fairly
easy to make the case that to whatever
part of the spectrum you're on you
probably don't want the government to
have full control and surveillance over
every single thing that everybody's
doing with their money and I think
that's the risk of Central Bank digital
currencies and why any technology that
kind of provides an alternative or
pushes back on that I think it's really
valuable which is why I think encryption
in general is valuable it's kind of an
inherently asymmetric technology and
then also any any monetary systems that
make use of it whether it's stable coins
or Bitcoin or uh decentralized like uh
information protocols those I think are
very important because I think that they
serve as um you know institutions in
away or or just pieces of technology
that kind of push back against the
excessive concentration of
power the book is broken money and like
I said at the top it's a mustre for
anyone interested in how money actually
works uh or the future of money uh
anywhere else I should Point our viewers
in order to find your work Lynn uh then
go to linen.com or yeah just check out
broken money and I appreciate the uh the
interview okay Lyn Alden thanks for
talking to Reon